the theft of more than 2 million dimes
dimes like actual coin dimes dimes bro
that's like 10
million no $20 million the other it's
$200,000 it's
$200,000 oh that's not worth it also so
heavy dude they should make that move oh
are you [__] me dude if they made
that movie and we're going to rob him in
dimes is what we're going to do first of
all we need 600
guys why do we need so many mate they're
so [__] heavy have you tried to carry
[__] 300 dimes you can't mate you
might think you can but you can't we got
to work out for [__] two years all of
us six we need 600 memberships to the
gym we [__] need them for two years
and then we're going to go rob two
million dimes we need 600 no we need
eight we need [__] 2,000 people is
what we
need freeze this is a robbery just so
many dudes in the [__] back it's so
150 guys got caught but you know
what dude two times earlier this year
from a tractor trailer okay from a
tractor trailer that had picked up the
coins from us Min in Philadelphia dude
imagine you're like dude let's get this
vent let's get this [__] van here we
go every is freeze and then it's just
full of Dimes oh for [__] sake dude
that would be my wife you we got the
dimes one Bab
great I knew we should have got the
other one but you wanted to follow the
other one I said it was driving
clunky I said it was driving clunky when
it went over the [__] potholes what
did it look like what did it look like
it looked
like lizo and and one of the people from
The View were [__] that's how how
much it looked like it was in
there the truck driver was bound for
Miami when he pulled into a parking lot
to sleep on April 13th during the night
thieves made off with a portion of of
its cargo of
750,000 in dimes a shipment weighing
about 6 tons I was right dude how do you
[__] where do you put it thousands of
coin were left scattered all over the
lot in Northeast
Philadelphia look at this
dude
two
100,000 234,00 and stolen
dimes where do you put it after that all
right is we to do we're going we'll get
[__] 2 million dimes we need 2,000
people to help us with this Heist we're
going to rush into the [__] bank all
right and then after that here's what
we're going to do we're going to deposit
them but we probably have to do it
like I don't know
$200 at a time otherwise people will
think like it's fishy you know
especially if like they know a lot of
Dimes are missing right so is what we're
going to do we're going to take flights
to other areas it's the most expensive
Heist to be honest we've got to pay
everyone [__] get the tickets to go
somewhere else ah [__] honestly we're
going to be in a hole after
this the plane flights to all the
different [__] States and [__] God
damn it we're we're too deep we're too
deep we can't back out
now
um detective said at the time the
surveillance video showed six men
dressed in gry hoodies who the [__] were
they Transformers how do you carry six
tons D you know who the guys are too
imagine the big ass [__] workout
dudes they're just
like imagine big ass workout dudes
[__] rob the bank and [__] just so
big they're like that dude that died
that is all all the memes right now or
or or um or just like uh the dude you
love the one that you always send that's
he died he's dead but the big ass
[__] workout they got like what's his
name Ronnie Co Coleman is that the guy
no that's the UFC guy whatever you know
what I'm talking about big ass [__]
dudes they look like Bradley Martin and
they're just [__] running around and
they're like they're like switching
outfits you know to so they don't get
caught but they still look like big ass
[__] and and the police are
like it's it's that guy like no he's in
a hoodie though ah it's not him it's
just another big guy
dude that's weird what how did guys get
so big I'm supposed to do Bradley
Martin's podcast actually I gotta text
him back
why do guys get so big that's
crazy H how big should I
get detective said at the time okay six
men middle of the night in the middle of
the
night approaching the
TRU look at this four men Ron oh here
they
are uh 31-year-old Ronald bird rakem
Savage hanif Palmer and Malik
Palmer dude how big are they
though wow can't be that
big just dragging it across a
concrete
wow divided by four is
50k worst Heist hey Rob a Target hey
dude get into [__] Bitcoin you know